so the thing to do is to steal IO just
for yourself and that's really what I
was saying then was this nice chatting
even inana I was on the mat and I was I
was talking to Marx Kesler you know
because I wanted to know what to not do
the right or wrong thing so I had but he
was very quite offer of me he give me a
quick instruction and you could see was
going into a firm shut up Ton now you
know we're waiting for s or we're
waiting for us to be ready on the M okay
so stand
please
so I've been sort of we say I've been
doing meditation for I think over 40
years about 44 45 years but I don't like
doing it because that means I've got to
sit and I've got to do you know I've got
to stop I like being busy but I've been
researching a lot lately the monkey mind
and uh I realize okay and then just so
I'm going to
bend
this think about what I done with Danny
your body needs to be nice UPL going to
bring the arms you're going to make a
hole and you're just going to look
through that
hole can you relax your arms without
moving from that space so you you just
tell yourself about Rel relaxing looking
through that space the monkey mind will
soon be with you and sort of make you
want to drift off and looking through
the space to perhaps looking to the side
or
something what you can do is you can
just go completely vacant by not
thinking of anything except just Pierce
yourself mentally and blank blank really
through that
hole check your arms again they might
got a little bit tense while I was
talking and while you
soften and you relax the arms perhaps
you'll get keep where you you are you
might get a tingling from your fingers
to the other to the other fingers you
might get a a nice tingling of sensation
what I'd like you to do now is just as
you look through the hole concentrate on
heat coming from your hands to each
hand so you're you're creating heat
you're pushing mental thought of
heat at the same time go down to your
Naval in thought and push from your navl
down into the legs the front of the legs
and down into the feet so the feet feel
like they're getting deeper and deeper
into the m
deeper and deeper into the
mat relaxing the arms deeper and deeper
into the
mat heat an energy coming from your
hands slowly lower them
good just don't hold your knee caps and
don't put your lace tight together just
a little turn of these
knees I just teach really of what my
body needs you know it might not be what
your body needs so my
hips with the shoulders as as still as
possible you know they're
not we're doing the hips not the
shoulders some people tend to not move
their shoulders about
other
way so from now on I'm going to be
teaching a different way where I'll be
showing rather than Breaking the
techniques down in the other
way and you'll be doing the work so
you'll be doing two on your partner they
you then they'll be getting up and doing
two on you and you don't have to do it
at speed but try and do it
constantly constant Pace come up and
over supporting your
side let the knees soften a little bit
now as you slightly lean back you're not
collapsing the
back
down up first before you go
over then when you're you've got a nice
place you bend the knees a little so
they're softening you just lean back a
little
bit my Tai Chu Master used to say to me
well he trained me really hard for I
know four months six months can't
remember now but he train me really hard
twice a day seven days a week and he
always kept saying strong legs means a
strong spine means good
health we used to smoke about 60
cigarettes a
day this time we're going to go up
support side
over and I'd like you to now bend the
knees sof and go back but now project
out of that upper arm as if you've got
heat again you don't have to think of it
as heat but if you think of it some form
of energy you should feel on the tatana
the blade of your hand you should feel a
sort of an energy or something different
than what you perhaps felt without the
thought are you shaking or can you can
you breathe out that that
tension you should be in this sort of
pose as if you're you're just hanging
there without effort structure of your
legs should hold you
up
okay on the
way
way the head
side
Center
side Center side Center tick it on it
side hold the stretch drop the opposite
shoulder breathe out as you bring the
head back
up over the other way drop the opposite
shoulder so you'll giving yourself a
nice stretch in the
neck breathe out bring it back
up okay now we just one of my old yoga
teachers he said think of putting a
pencil in your mouth and trying to draw
the perfect circle slowly
if you try and go too
far the pencil or imaginary pencil will
shake because you're trying to go
outside a limit and you're trying to
really get
this nice
Circle then when you're ready go the
other
way
sh your hand in your own time I'd like
you to do forward and
back